the six the
buy don't worry if you don't feel
anything on this one it's difficult so
you think of the
first so start off just with this little
light
swing think the
first once you've done that a few times
you just go into the second you just do
that a few times you go into the second
and you just do that a few times just go
into the
second a few
times then you bring the back foot up to
nearly touch the other one so there's
two ways of doing it and then you just
do
that okay so back into the second cut
bring the back foot
up and it's like a little boom
back up here cut back foot up boom so
there's two there's two ways there's cut
and that without the back foot coming up
so there's
here go without the back foot coming out
or his son designed this and it's a very
nice one he's
here if you got a bit more time it's
quite a nice one so I just sense his Sun
uh created this one so I use it cuz I
like it but his father
went just without the back
foot